Галина Молоканова викладає зарубіжну літературу в Бучанському ліцеї №5.
Доброго дня, діти, доброго!
Жінка жила в Лисичанську, поки війна у квітні не змусила її залишити місто.
На Луганщині вона свого часу вивчилася на вчителя української, але викладала і російську мову.
У побуті, каже, українську було чути рідко.
Не дивлячись на те, що ми вдома розмовляли російською, співали ми завжди українською.
Діду подобалася "Чом дуб не зелений". І йому завжди співали: "Чом дуб не зелений, бо хмара закрила, козак невеселий, лихая година".
Галина розповідає, що в переважно російськомовному середовищі ніхто не замислювався над тим, що мова може стати зброєю.
Знали, як потрібно, але робили, як зручніше. Тоді якось не думалося взагалі. Не вважалося це проблемою.
Якщо б у нас була, не знаю, чи не образливо, - китайська мова, то ми викладали б і цією.
А зараз…  Це стало якоюсь бомбою тривалої дії.
У Бучі, де Галина знайшла прихисток, війна не дає про себе забути.
Усі школи на Київщині в новому навчальному році відмовилися від російської мови як предмета і мови навчання.
На Одещині, Житомирщині, Черкащині, Львівщині, Миколаївщині регіональні адміністрації також оголосили, що російської в школах більше не буде.
На думку Галини Молоканової, це правильний, але запізнілий крок.
Мені здається, що це потрібно було раніше робити все ж таки. Такого б не було, що відбувається зараз.
Натомість Тетяна з Одеси не вважає, що російська мова стала приводом для нападу Росії.
Вона - мама семикласниці. Її донька Єлизавета до шостого класу навчалася російською, торік перейшла на українську.
Тетяна сумнівається у правильності рішення Одеської обласної адміністрації щодо відмови від предмету "російська мова" у школах.
Тепер батьки можуть попросити хіба що факультативні заняття.
З одного боку, переповнюють почуття стосовно нинішньої ситуації і мені самій хочеться дуже часто вчити українську,
спілкуватися українською, тому що я себе почуваю українкою. Але настільки ж я розумію, що мова тут ні до чого.
І такий пласт культури як російська мова і література просто прибрати з наших шкіл, зі свідомості наших дітей - я не думаю, що це правильно.
Одеситка говорить, що її донька - справжня патріотка і знання російської мови цьому не завадить.
Коли сплине час, коли Україна переможе, розум переможе, і повага до того, що в Україні живуть багато російськомовних людей…
Мені здається, розум має переважити.
Насправді кількість повністю російськомовних шкіл в Україні за останні роки невпинно скорочувалася.
Про це свідчать дані Міністерства освіти і науки України.
Якщо у 2015/2016 навчальному році працювали 614 шкіл з навчанням російською мовою,
то вже у минулому навчальному році таких шкіл налічувалося лише 35.
У понад трьох тисячах навчальних закладів учні ще вивчали російську мову як самостійний предмет.
Цей колись російськомовний ліцей у Броварах з 2015 року поступово перейшов на українську.
З яких частин складаються веди? - З чотирьох.
На уроці зарубіжної літератури усі восьмикласники вільно говорять українською, хоча з першого класу навчалися російською мовою.
З п'ятого - перейшли на українську, але мали по уроку російської на тиждень. Після 24 лютого від таких уроків відмовилися, розповідає класна керівниця.
Вона сама раніше викладала російську.
Більшість батьків "за" і мене підтримали, коли я сказала, що відмовлюся розповсюджувати російську мову і культуру як мову агресора,
я відмовляюся це робити, і вони зі мною погодилися, тому що зараз це уже просто аморально.
Директорка пояснює, що у ліцеї традиційно навчаються діти різних національностей:
грузини, узбеки, азербайджанці, корейці. Тому батьки і просили у адміністрації додавати уроки російської. Після 24 лютого усе змінилося.
Деякі батьки були проти, тому що спілкування, хоча ми їм говорили - будь ласка, можете спілкуватися, але викладання має бути лише українською мовою,
і ми змогли переконати батьків, що наприклад, у 8-Д класі ми просто їм додали годину англійської мови.
Нині педагоги замислюються над тим, що варто було б раніше відмовитися від уроків російської,
але, кажуть, не могли цього зробити без запиту від батьків.
Поки на перервах у шкільних коридорах чути здебільшого російську, але за словами учителів, учні стараються опановувати державну.
Зокрема, й діти інших національностей.
До сих пір діти різних національностей навчаються у нас в школі.
Вони так само розмовляють українською мовою, і ви навіть не відчуєте різницю між українцями і ними. Можливо, трошечки акцент буде.
Офіційної заборони на вивчення російської в Україні немає.
Як пояснили в Міносвіти у відповідь на запит DW, у шкіл є право самостійно складати навчальні програми, зокрема й щодо вивчення мов.
Тож чи будуть у школі уроки російської чи будь-якої іншої мови національних меншин - це зрештою вибір батьків і адміністрації закладу.
Також у МОН нагадують: тоді як національні та етнічні меншини мають право на вивчення рідної мови,
за законом, освітній процес в українських школах має відбуватися державною мовою.